[Musique]
je suis antoine des jeunes républicains
du bas-rhin et je m'exprime aujourd'hui
pour montrer que les jeunes républicains
partout en france sont encore investi
dans la vie politique
les jeunes républicains sont la preuve
que la jeunesse actuelle est encore
investi dans la vie politique et que
celle ci n'est pas réservé à une et je
me suis engagé je n'ai jamais
républicain parce que j'ai constaté
autour de moi dans mon milieu
professionnel chez les jeunes qui
m'entoure de plus en plus de difficultés
à trouver un travail à trouver une
orientation en france aujourd'hui est
d'autant plus avec la crise économique
et sociale que nous traversons
chercherait plus qu'à nous partons du
principe qu'il n'a pas le droit sans
devoir nous sommes aussi le mouvement
qui défend notre identité alsacienne en
faisant partie de la majorité à djassem
les jeunes républicains ce sont des
visites d'entreprises des visites
d'institutions des congrès des
rencontres avec des élus locaux et
nationaux
mais c'est avant tout échanger sur la
vie politique et sur les sujets qui nous
tiennent à coeur
républicain c'est un signe surtout
l'europe il est primordial de conserver
la paix et la bonne entente au sein de
l'union européenne
en promouvant le bilinguisme et les
échanges entre les jeunes en tant que
jeune républicain du bas rhin il est
évident de défendre le siège unique du
parlement européen à strasbourg
au delà de la dimension symbolique c'est
un élément d'attractivité et de
rayonnement indispensable dont bénéficie
toute l'alsace 30000 emplois dépendent
de nos institutions européennes il faut
les conserver jeunes républicains
souhaitent porter la voix de cette
jeunesse qui veut se battre pour elle
qui veut y arriver mais qui
aujourd'hui éprouvent de plus en plus
des difficultés métier est terminée nous
défendrons toujours la culture du mérite
et pas l'assistanat
notre mouvement est présent à strasbourg
et bien sûr dans toutes les villes du
bas rhin de sélestat jusqu'à décembre
chez les jeunes républicains nous
souhaitons qu'ils aient un capital
formation qu'ils soient mis en place
pour les salariés et pour les jeunes
entrepreneurs pour remplacer les
dispositifs actuels qui sont illisibles
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux
chaque jour n'aurait plus qu'un on
constate également un sentiment que nous
voulons absolument combattre c'est le
sentiment d'insécurité et hausse
considérable des agressions une flambée
de violence de la métropole alsacienne
il faut qu'ils aient une meilleure
information pour les jeunes dès le
collège de tous les dispositifs qui
existent pour eux et pour cela on nous
proposons la mise en place
l'augmentation du nombre de semaines de
stage pour leur permettre de découvrir
le monde qui les entoure le monde de
l'entreprise
le républicain du bas rhin nous sommes
une team dynamique engagée et en action
permanente
nous sommes avant tout un groupe d'amis
mais nous sommes résolument engagés pour
notre région notre pays et sa jeunesse
notre mouvance et des valeurs comme la
solidarité le mérite le travail et des
propositions concrètes qui sont liées
comme vous avez pu entendre la parole
temps nous avons également la chance
dans le bas-rhin de bénéficier des
locaux comme chalandre eu à peine 23 ans
et les merdes dachstein
nous sommes très fiers d'être à ses
côtés nous organisons également des
événements locaux
tous les mois et n'attendez plus
rejoignez
[Musique]